the goal for this movie was definitely  to up the ante as much as we could there  were a lot of characters that people who  are anticipating seeing Kirk and Spock  bones Scotty over a check off and Sulu I  am more excited I can tell you the  action in this movie the scale of the  movie is light years beyond what we did  in the first movie  it was pretty magical to see what they  were able to create this time I think  it's stunningly beautiful the word of  keep on coming back to just relentless  there's one thing after another after  another after another this is the kind  of film in 3d was made for without  question the imax and 3d of it i think  will give viewers yet another level of  excitement this movie was the most fun  and challenging experience that I've had  this is like everything I've ever done  back to in one movie